is lunchtime maybe you're hungry the  latest and greatest in the world of  pizza being shown off right here in the  valley this week it's the 2022 pizza  expo  certainly a tasty tradition that's a  staple here in our valley one of the  prevailing trends this year  plant-based options so we caught up with  danny o'malley the owner of before the  butcher it's a plant-based meat company  out of san diego talking about what's  changing in the plant-based industry  what's great about these products today  is they they are evolving and getting  better and better and really the purpose  behind these are to mimic animal based  proteins so people that eat regular  animal based proteins regularly will try  this and say hey wow that that's very  similar it tastes like and why not  about the texture o'malley's showing off  his product at the pizza expo along with  dozens of others international pizza  expo in its 38th year it runs  from march 21st to the 24th